de passage dans la région ce client n'a
pas hésité à faire un long détour pour
venir acheter son fromage directement à
la ferme
faisons nos courses chez des petits
propriétaires les petits cultivateurs se
prête plus frais ici les volaille les
oeufs et les légumes bio en attirer de
nouveaux clients durant le confinement
mais depuis quelques jours c'est un peu
la désillusion
on s'est bien rendu compte que après le
déconfinement les gens sont moins venus
ou en tout cas nous ceux qui viennent
encore ce sont ceux qui venaient déjà
avant donc ça change rien mais des
nouveaux clients on en a pas donc on est
bien obligé de se rendre compte que les
grandes surfaces sont repartis à fond et
que les gens ne change absolument rien à
leur mode de consommation
une vente directe chez des producteurs
plébiscité durant la période de
confinement plus d'un tiers des
consommateurs déclaré vouloir favoriser
les circuits courts
aujourd'hui certaines ventes directes
continue de susciter l'engouement comme
ici chez ce producteur de fraises on
cuisine beaucoup plus ont fait plus de
gâteau on marche beaucoup plus allemande
on a envie de voir ce qu'on mange non de
cueillir ce qu'on mange et tout donc oui
ça a été un peu influencé les
changements d'habitudes alimentaires ou
simple envie de plein air en 42 ans
d'activité le personnel de cette
exploitation a rarement vu une telle
affluence les gens ils viennent plus
dans les circuits courts et cueillir ce
qu'ils aiment c'est cueillir leurs
légumes me choisir faire leurs
confitures
c'est ce qu'ils veulent ces nouveaux
comportements disparaîtront t-il après
l'épidémie
à la sortie du confinement un
consommateur sur cinq déclaré vouloir
privilégier l'achat de produits locaux